MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we continue our discussion,
our development of QED
as a discussion of the photon.
We have already seen how
we can describe electrons
and positrons, anti-electrons.
And now it's time
to actually look
at the quantum of
electromagnetic fields.
A few general remarks first,
quantum electrodynamic
is a quantum field theory--
the quantum field
theory of electrodynamic
processes describing how
light interacts with matter.
Specifically, all
processes where
a photon is used as an
exchange particle involving
electrically-charged particles
can be described by QED.
The photon is in the
limit theory particle.
And it's a quantum of the
electromagnetic field.
But the real power in
QED lies in the fact
that we can describe it
as a perturbation theory.
We'll see that we can write
down Feynman diagrams,
calculate them, and use those
calculations to describe
processes we can
observe in experiment.
And since we can do this
with a very high precision,
we can use QED in order to
make forecasts, in order
to understand, in order to
understand inner dynamics
of processes we can measure.
Feynman called QED
our pride and joy.
And it's in the really unmatched
precision of this theory
where the pride and joy lies.
But stepping back one step.
Let's start with just
local election dynamics.
And let's start from
Maxwell's equations.
And I'm going to use this
just to make a few points
and remarks.
This is really not in the
direct path of our development,
but it connects the
dots to something
you have already
started, meaning
classical electrodynamics.
So you all have seen
Maxwell equations.
They can be expressed in
integral or differential form.
And you can write this even more
compact than it's given here.
So you see Gauss's law.
And you see that electric
charge generate electric fields
you can see that you
can produce currents
by time changing electric
fields or by spatially
changing magnetic fields.
Gauss's law for
magnetic fields saying
that there is no magnetic
charge, no magnetic monopole,
at least as far as we know.
We have not observed those.
And then there's
Faraday's law as well.
You can express the magnetic
field and the electric field
through vector potentials.
And if you go one
step further, you
see this very nice
form using four vectors
for the potential and
the vector potential
and the charge and the current.
So what we're really
doing here right now
is we're just rewriting
the very same equations.
And so when we use this
[INAUDIBLE] operator,
the form of this
equation looks like this.
You can already see
this form is very
similar to the Klein-Gordon
equation we just looked at.
So let's go down this
path a little bit more.
So this here is yet another form
to write the Maxwell equations,
where f is our field
strength tensor.
And the field strength tenor
has all the physics involved.
You see that you're describing
the electromagnetic field
and its components.
And then the simplification
of the Maxwell equations
are sitting here.
So we have the Maxwell
equation in this form.
We have the Maxwell
equation in this form here.
So there's one
interesting thing when
we use potential in
order to describe
electromagnetic
processes or properties,
is that we can actually choose
the specifics of the gauge.
There's a degree
of freedom which
we can choose, which doesn't
have any impact on the physics,
on the reality of the physics.
And you can see this here.
If you do the choice
that this component is 0,
this is called
the Coulomb gauge.
We basically simplify
again our Maxwell equations
to this point here.
Great.
So there's a number
of things to be said.
So what we are basically
doing here, if we fix a gauge,
so if you fix our potential, we
tie the choice of the potential
to the inertial frame
we're using here.
And you could say
that's not nice.
That doesn't seem
[INAUDIBLE] invariant.
It is actually OK to do this.
The issue with that
is that you tie--
if you go from one
frame in the other,
you have to actually
change the gauge
as you go along with
changing the reference frame.
But there's nothing bad, it's
just a little bit awkward.
All right, then moving back
so we have this equation now.
And this equation,
obviously simplifies.
If there's no current or no
charge around for free photons.
So this one, and for this
you can find the solution
is again the free rates.
This was the goal
of this lecture,
finding this free weight.
So you could have
probably written this down
before any of the
discussion, but I just
want to makes some connection.
So now this in the
QED, this a mu,
becomes our big
function for the photon.
Again, we have to this is as
a result of the we gauge made.
So we made specific choice
in our reference frame.
And then we can describe the
photon with our wave function.
That is epsilon here, epsilon
is our polarization vector.
And is a normalization factor.
We always have to
normalize our wave function
to a specific set of unit.
All right, that's good.
We can now analyze this.
We find that those conditions
are fulfilled here,
basically saying that
photon decays like a photon.
The energy of the photon is
equal to the momentum times C.
That's great.
But it's also not a
surprise because the form
of this equation
here is exactly that
of the Klein-Gordon equation
not for massless particles.
In the Klein-Gordon
equation we got
from this very
same relationship,
so I was not surprised
that this works out.
All right, one more word
on the polarization vector.
So the choice you just made--
I'm resulting the choice here.
This is our Coulomb
requires that the zeros
component of our
polarization vector is a0.
And that the polarization vector
is orthogonal to the momentum
vector.
So in principle, you
have the three vector.
The three vector is
perpendicular to the direction
of motion.
And that allows us to find
two polarization states which
are independent of each other.
So different to our
electrons before.
Now we don't have four states.
You only have two states
with independent solutions
for a given momentum.
All right, so with this
now, we have elections.
We can describe those.
We can describe photons.
The next step now is to look
at the Feynman rules which
allows us to describe the
interaction between those two.